he is on Facebook can you explain why
you why you should put off investing in
retirement until you're dead free yes
because your most powerful wealth
building tool is your income and when
you're paying it all out on debt
payments you don't have the money to
invest for retirement
most people screw around just put a
couple of points in their retirement and
you need to be saving 15% of your
household income for retirement and you
can't do that with a stupid car payment
a student loan that's been around so
long you think it's a pet American
distress and discovered bondage that's
why you've given away your financial
power when you signed up for all these
stupid payments so get rid of the stupid
payments so you can start doing smart
retirement investing that's why it's a
ransom math thing and here's the thing
Brittany if people that try to do six
things at once don't get any of them
done there's a power of focus and if you
focus on getting out of debt and stop
everything else and you stop everything
else and you stop everything else while
you focus on getting out of debt you'll
get out of debt but if you try to get
out of debt and try to do retirement and
try to save for my kids college and try
to get a house and I oh yeah and I
wanted to buy a car oh yeah and I went
you know I know we're going on vacation
you try to do 63 things at once nothing
happens and that's what broke people do
they'll walk walk around looking like
there's something and they're broke what
tell if they say in Texas big hat no
cattle
that's the deal and so you got a you
know you got to lean into stuff and
completely focus on it to cause it to
move that's why I say to temporarily
temporarily stop investing and focus
completely and utterly on the debt get
mad until you do that you won't get out
of debt you see this culture of debt is
so prevalent and everybody's got debt
and when you start talking about getting
out of debt you're so weird there's so
much pressure for you to be normal and
broke instead of weird
people are always bugging you they're
looking at you like like you've lost
your ever-lovin mind they roll your eyes
when you say I'm going to cut up my
credit cards they roll their eyes when
you say I'm never going to have another
credit card again they're so
condescending in their brokenness and
there they sit in their brokenness and
there's there's just so much pressure so
much belief that you're always going to
have a car payment the language of
losers ever heard that I used to say I
had the language of losers I grew up
with guys you're always gonna have a car
payment little man can't get ahead I
sure hope somebody will get elected
it'll fix my life
hmm ee or is there spirit animal you
know what I'm talking about and you
can't be that guy if you're going to win
you got to be focused intense and be
ready for the broke people to think
you're weird and that's what I mean you
just can't do all this stuff so it's not
an intellectual problem it's a visceral
emotional behavior modification thing
and that makes you free of debt and when
you are free of debt then you have when
you have no payments you know what
you've got your money mathematically
you're free the Bible says the borrower
is slave to the lender and I had a
spiritual experience a few years ago I
discovered God smarter than me and so if
you don't agree with that you're what's
known as wrong the borrower is slave to
the lender you don't believe me get rid
of all your payment's when the payments
are gone you tell me you didn't you
weren't walking in slavery but sometimes
slaves are so used to being slaves they
don't even know they're slaves anymore
they got a good master Master Card yeah
give me a break this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]